تتقدم في باخموت من جهه الشمال والجيش
الاوكراني يسقط 610 مسيرات ايرانيه منذ
سبتمبر
مباحثات امنيه اسرائيليه فلسطينيه بمشاركه
امريكيه اردنيه ومصريه لبحث التهدئه ووقف
العنف
مدير المخابرات الامريكيه يؤكد ان ايران
قادره على تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه 90%
خلال اسابيع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نبدا النشره من هذه الصور التي
وصلتنا من باكستان حيث افادت تقارير
باكستانيه بمقتل اربعه اشخاص هو اصابه
اثني عشر اخرين بانفجار عبوه ناسفه ثبتت
في دراجه ناريه بسوق شعبيه
وذلك في منطقه بارخان التابعه الاقليمي
بلوشستان التقارير مشاهدينا ذكرت ان
المستشفيات اعلنت حاله الطوارئ عقب
الانفجار ولم تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليتها عن عن
الهجوم حتى الان ومزينا معكم مشاهدينا اذا
في متابعه هذه الصور من اقليم بارخان في
باكستان حيث افادت تقارير باكستانيه بمقتل
اربعه اشخاص واصابه 12 اخرين في انفجار
عبوه ناسفه ثبتت على درجه ناريه في سوق
شعبيه
نواصل نشاط من تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه
حيث اعلن سلاح الجو الاوكراني اسقاط 1200
صاروخ وطائره مثيره سبتمبر الماضي سلاح
الجو الاوكراني اوضح انه اسقط
650 صاروخ روسيا و600
ايرانيه الصنع
وعلى جبهه بخموت المشتعله قال العقيد في
الجيش الاوكراني يوري ماديار شبكه
على الرغم من تحسين كبير للقوات الروسيه
بالقرب من البلده الشرقيه واكد مليار ان
القوات الاوكرانيه احتفظ بمواقعها في جميع
المداخل الثلاثه لباخمت وان عمليات هجوم
العدو باءت بالفشل حسب تعبيره ولم تحقق
نجاحات اقليميه على حد وصفه ايضا متوقعا
ان يشن الروس عده عمليات هجوميه عند
تمركزهم الكبير في باخد
من جهته اعلى نقائد قوات فاغن الروسيه
السيطره على بلده يقديني شماليه مدينه
باخمود بعد مواجهه مع القوات الاوكرانيه
تمكنت بعدها فاجنر من الوصول الى اخر نقاط
السيطره الاوكرانيه
بطريقها الى البوابه الشماليه من باخت
فيما افاد مراسله العربي بان القوات
الاوكرانيه فجرت احد سدود نهر سيفسكي لوقف
تقدم في باك بعد انسحابها من بلدات تابعه
للمدينه
هذا وفرض الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبات جديده
على مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه لاتهاكها حقوق
حقوق الانسان في عدد من الدول الافريقيه
وجاء في بيان للمجلس الاوروبي ان العقوبات
الاخيره فرضت نظرا الى البعد الدولي
للمجموعه وخطوره نشاطاتها بالاضافه الى
تاثيرها المزعزعه الاستقرار في البلدان
التي تنشط فيها
[موسيقى]
وفي مداخلته اليوميه عبر الفيديو قال رئيس
الاوكراني اوكرانيا قادره على الانتصار
هذا العام مضيفا ان المانيا تساعد في
حمايه الاوكرانيين مما وصفه بالارهاب
الروسي
هل يمكن ان ننتصر نعم نحن قادرون على ذلك
في وحده وحزم وبلاوات نحن قادرون على وضع
حد للعدوان الروسي هذا العام كانت المانيا
معنا منذ الدقائق الاولى من الغزو الروسي
المانيا تساعدنا في حمايه الاوكرانيين من
الارهاب الروسي وستكون معنا في يوم
الانتصار
روسيا مشاهدينا نقل عن مسؤول كبير قول حين
بلاده لديها ما يصل الى مليون ونصف مليون
جندي المحتمل خارج القوات المسلحه وذلك
بعد ان امر رئيس البيلاروسي لوكاشينكو هذا
الشهر بتشكيل قوه دفاع اقليميه جديده من
المتطوعين يصل قوامها الى 150 الف فرد
مؤكدا ان جيشه هولن يقاتل الا في حال تمت
مهاجمه بيلاروسيا
بدات كرواتيا الاستعدادات لعمليه ارسال
اربعه عشره مروحيه نقل الى اوكرانيا تم
فصل 12 طائرات هليكوبتر من طراز ام اي 8
ام تي في واحد وطائرته هليكوبتر من طراز
المسلحه وتشير التقديرات الى ان طائرات
الهليكوبتر ستكون جاهزه للنقل في غضون
عشره ايام حيث سيتم نقل جميع طائرات
هليكوبتر ال14 بدايه الى بولندا وصولا الى
اوكرانيا
متواصل ايضا حيال مقترح الصين للسلام في
اشترت الحفاظ على مناطق سيطرت عليها خيار
الحرب ام الولايات المتحده فشككت في الخطه
قبل ان يرفضها الرئيس جو بايدن
اذا كان بوتين يصفق لها فكيف يمكن ان تكون
جيده انا لا اريد ان اكون طريفا انا جاد
للغايه لم ارى شيئا في الخطه يشير الى
انها ستكون مفيده لاي احد اخر غير روسيا
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون الذي اعلن
انه سيزور الصين مطلع الشهر المقبل اكد ان
السلام ممكن واصفا جهود بالامر الجيد
لافتا الى دورها في الضغط على روسيا
ياتي ذلك غداه نقل صحيفه وولد جورنال عن
مصادر ان باريس ولندن ابلغت الرئيس
الاوكراني
فولوديميرزلينسكي بضروره الاخذ بعين
الاعتبار مفاوضات السلام
زيلينسكي رحب ببعض عناصر المقترح الصيني
لوقف اطلاق النار لكنه قال ان الدوله التي
تدور فيها الحرب هي التي ينبغي ان تطلق
خطه السلام ان كانت هناك افكار تتوافق
بطريقه او باخرى مع احترام القانون الدولي
وسلامه الاراضي فلنعمل مع الصين في هذه
النقطه من جهتها قالت روسيا حليفه الصين
انها تقدر جهود لوضع حد للنزاع مع تشديدها
على ضروره الاعتراف بضم موس اربع مناطق
اوكرانيه تطالب بها
المندوب الروسي لدى مجلس الامن قال ايضا
ان وضع حد للاعمال القتاليه في اوكرانيا
سيسمح للعالم بالتعافي اما الامم المتحده
فقد اعتبرت خارطه السلام الصينيه بشان
اوكرانيا مساهمه مهمه
خطه الصين تحث كلا الجانبين على الاتفاق
على خفض تدريجي للتصعيد وتحذر من استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
بلال البجدين العربيه
قال نائب رئيس البرلمان الاوكراني في
مقابله خاصه العربيه ان وثيقه السلام التي
اعلن عنها رئيسكي بسيطه وواضحه يتضمن
انسحاب روسيا من اراضينا بشكل كامل وعوده
حدودنا الى ما قبل
وثيقه السلام التي اعلن عنها الرئيس
زلينسكي اقرت في قمه مجموعه دول العشرين
نحن في اوكرانيا نرى انها قمه 19 دوله لان
روسيا لا تستحق ان تكون بينها وثيقه
السلام بسيطه وتستند الى مبادئ واضحه مثلا
انسحاب روسيا من اراضينا وعوده قواتها الى
موسكو من دون باس والقرم ايضا وعوده
حدودنا الى ما قبل
1991 موقف اوكرانيا واضح وقوي ويدعمه
الاوكرانيون نحن واضحون لا نريد اي تسويه
مع روسيا على حساب سيادتنا بعد كل ما
عانيناه من ويلات الحرب وم في الاسلحه
التي استخدمتها روسيا لتدمير بلدنا
قساوه الحرب الاوكرانيه وهي تدخل عامها
الثاني لم تغفي المدى تاثير القوه الناعمه
في استماره التعاطف مع الاوكرانيين في
حربهم هذا ما فعله نجمه هوريوت الذين
ابكت الرئيس الاوكراني
اوكرانيا الغربيه ينتقل الى عالم
الفنز
نحو 30 نجما يوجهون رساله دعم للاوكرانيين
من خلال منصه لجمع تبرعات اعاده بناء
اوكرانيا
منصه يونايتد تونيفور بثت فيديو الدعم في
ذكرى مرور عام على الحرب من بين هؤلاء
ماديمون
الحب والتضامن مع جميع اخواننا في
اوكرانيا
تعددت الرسائل ومحتوى التضامن واحد من
بينها رساله جوليا روبرت
نفكر فيكم ونرسل اليكم الحب ونرسل لكم
قوتنا ودعواتنا ونبقيكم دائما في قلوبنا
وغيرهما من فنانين ومثقفين ورياضيين
مشاركه واسعه وشكر من الرئيس الاوكراني
على رسائل الدعم
علي السمان العربيه
هذا اظهر مقطع فيديو اخر بطل العالم
السابق في الوزن الثقيل للملاكمه
الاوكراني فلاديمير وهو شقيق عمله
ظهر يقود دبابه ليوبارت المانيه التي
تسلمتها
لم افكر مطلقا انني ساقود هذه عام من
الحرب في اوكرانيا عام من المعاناه وعام
جديد ايضا من تعزيز قوه ارادتنا اكثر من
اي وقت مضى اراده قويه شكرا المانيا على
هذه الدبابه شكرا للعالم على كل ما
يفعلونه لنا ايها الاوكرانيون المجد
لاوكرانيا المجد للابطال
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا او فيها بعد
الفاصل
الحلبوس يتوجه الى دمشق على راس وفد
برلماني عربي ويطالب بعودتها الى الحضن
العربي
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد نستانف نشره
سميع العقبه الاردنيه حيث انطرق قبل قليل
اجتماع بين كبار المسؤولين الامريكيين
والسياسيين الاسرائيليين وفلسطينيين
بمشاركه امريكيه واردنيه ومصريه وذلك في
محاوله لوقف موجه العنف التي اندلعت في
الاونه الاخيره بين الجانبين الاجتماع
الذي سيعقد ليوم واحد في ميناء العقبه
سيجمع للمره الاولى منذ سنوات بين كبار
قاده الامن الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
وقالت مصادر لصحيفه شرق الاوسط انت
الاجتماع سيشهد طرح الوفد الامريكي خطه
تهدئه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وبالاخص في
الضفه الغربيه المصادر اضافت ان الخطه
ترتكز بالاساس على وقف الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه للمناطق التابعه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه واطلاق يد الاجهزه الامنيه
الفلسطينيه في سيطره على المناطق التابعه
لها وافادت بان الخطه الامريكيه تتضمن
ايضا اعاده هيكله وترتيب تلك الاجهزه لتضم
نحو خمسه الاف ضابط وجندي فلسطيني في
المقابل استنكرت فص الفلسطينيه مشاركه وفد
من السلطه في اجتماع قالت انه استكمالا
لما وصفته بمخططات التامر على الشعب
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه اكدت في بيان ان الوفد
المشاركه سيشدد على ضروره وقف جميع
الاعمال الاحاديه الاسرائيليه والتزام
بالاتفاقيات الموقعه
اكد مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه في مقابله مع شبكه
90% خلال اسابيع لكنه قال انه لا يعتقد
بان المرشد الايراني اتخذ قرارا باستئناف
عسكره برنامج بلاده النووي
شهدت العاصمه الايراني احتجاجات في حياي
فرماانيه وتشيتكر حيث عانت الاسطوح شعارات
مناهضه لرموز النظام من قبيل الموت
لخامنئي ولن يكون الوطن وطنا الا بدفن
الملل
[موسيقى]
افادت مصادر العربيه بان رئيس مجلس النواب
العراقي محمد الحلبوسي سيتوجه اليوم بصفته
رئيس الاتحاد البرلماني العربي على راس
وفد برلماني العربي وعراقي الى العاصمه
السوريه دمشق لتقديم الدعم والمسانده
للسوريين بعد زلزال الذي تعرضت له مدن
سوريه وتاتي هذه الزياره بعد يوم واحد من
انعقاد مؤتمر الاتحاد البرلماني العربي في
دورته الرابعه والثلاثين في بغداد والتي
دعا فيها الاتحاد بل دعا فيها الاتحاد الى
العمل على عوده سوريا الى محيطها العربي
اعلنت رئاسه اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه عن ارتفاع عدد قتل زلزال الى اكثر
من 44 الف قتيل ياتي ذلك في وقت كشفت
السلطات التركيه عن بدء بناء منازل جديده
المتضررين ضمن خطط اعاده اعمال المناطق
المنكوبه في احدى عشره ولايه ضربها زلزال
بالتوازي مع عمليات اعاده الاعمار هذه
تواصل السلطات بناء مساكن مؤقته بدلا من
الخيام في مئه وثلاثين منطقه ضمن الولايات
المتضرره من الزلزال
من بلده نورداغ في ولايه غازي عنتاب
زيدانجلو
اكد رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه ينوي
اعلان ترشحه لولايه ثانيه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقرره في 2024 لكنه لن يقدم
على هذه الخطوه الان
مع بعض من الضحك والسخريه اكد رئيس
الامريكي جبيد نيته الترشح لولايه ثانيه
وهو امر اتبعه الرؤساء الامريكيون
واحزابهم في التاريخ المعاصر
يبدو ان احدهم سال زوجته عن ترشحه وعلي ان
اتصل بها واسالها الحقيقه ان نيه دائما ان
اترشح لكن علي ان انهي امورا عديده قبل ان
ابدا الحمله الانتخابيه نفهم من كلام
الرئيس الامريكي ان خوضه الانتخابات
المقبله مؤكد لكن اطلاق الحمله الانتخابيه
رهن باعمال الرئاسه وفي مقدمتها الاقتصاد
وحرب اوكرانيا
انا لا اتصور بان الرئيس بايدن هو خطير
على الحزب الجمهوري لانه
السياسه التي يقوم بها واداره الرئيس
بايدن بالفعل بالنسبه للوضع الداخلي هو
وضع اقتصادي ينهار يوما بعد يوم والتضخم
المالي لم يستطيعوا حتى الان لتوقيف هذا
التضخم المالي الحاصل وثانيا بالنسبه
للسياسه الخارجيه هناك وجه اخر لترشح بيضا
عن الديمقراطيين فشعبيه نائبه الرئيس كمال
هاريس ليست عاليه وربما تخسر الانتخابات
امام الرئيس السابق والمرشح الجمهوري
دونالد ترامب فالناخبون يفضلون الجمهوريين
لكن من المرجح ان ينتصر بيضا على ترامب
بنسبه 3% فيما تخسر هرس امام الرئيس
السابق بنسبه 5%
ما زالت الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
تقوم على سؤال اساسي وهو فوز او خساره
ترامب فهكذا كانت في الدولتين السابقتين
وهي هكذا الان ربما الرئيس ترامب ضعفت
شعبيته منذ سنتين ولكن اليوم نشعر بان
شعبيته تزداد يوما بعد يوم لانه بالمصائب
التي تضرب الولايات المتحده السياسه
الداخليه والخارجيه واداره الرئيس بايدن
لم تتعاطى معها
بالواجب حسب قدره الولايات المتحده ربما
نشهد في الانتخابات المقبله اعاده لمشهد
العام 2020 جزء اساسي من ذلك هو المنافس
الشخصيه بين الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن
والرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في الغنم
العربيه واشنطن
مشاهدينا نختم من باكستان حيث ارتفع عدد
قتلا انفجار عبوه ناسفه الى خمسه واصابه
سته عشر اخرين مسؤول في الشرطه مشاهدينا
ذكر ان العبوه الناسفه ثبتت في درجه ناريه
بسوق شعبيه وتم تفجيرها عن بعد تقارير
ايضا مشاهدينا ذكرت ان المستشفيات اعلنت
حاله الطوارئ
وبقي في الختام نذكر بعبرز العناوين
من جهه الشمال والجيش الاوكراني يسقط 610
مسيرات ايرانيه سبتمبر
بدء مباحثات امنيه اسرائيليه فلسطينيه في
العقبه بمشاركه امريكيه اردنيه ومصريه
لبحث التهدئه ووقف العنف
مدير المخابرات الامريكيه يؤكد ان ايران
قادره على تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه 90 في
المئه خلال اسابيع
نهايه النصر مشاهدينا كنا
[موسيقى]